hello there guys and welcome to another
commentary video in this video we're
going to be going over a
very interesting deleted scene this one
is from revenge of the seth again
and it's called a cry for help it's been
documented in the
making of revenge of the sif book so
yeah let's get into the video
the scene where obi-wan defeats anakin
was originally slightly longer
and included additional dialogue between
the two men
after everything what happened between
them are mustafar and everything
anakin has done everyone's first impulse
is to reach out to help the man who
became his brother
and anakin's first impulse is to reach
out to obi-wan
for help anakin's cry for help together
rui's outstretched hand
is actually left intact in the movie
even through the sound was mooted
you can actually see hayden
christensen's lips clearly pronounced in
the words
christian sin groans to get into
character and then gives an emotional
delivery of the two lines
help me master and
in the making of revenge of the seth
book it actually documents the filament
of that dialogue and there is actual
behind-the-scenes footage where obi-wan
refuses to help the fallen jedi
it's only then the anakin's eyes turn
from blue
to the sith red this revelation adds a
new dimension to the scene
that makes it even more heartbreaking i
love you but i can't help you
it's the lion from obi-wan kenobi
according to the book
after anakin implores obi-wan to save
him george lucas asked owen mcgregor to
say
i will not softer almost to himself
because anakin burst it into flames
it's as if obi-wan was talking to a dead
person
that's why he also suggested to drive
home this point that mcgregor changed
the words in the script
to the past tensed i loved you ellen
agreed well pointed out that his line
would have to change too but i could not
help you
lucas also explained that what obi-wan
is basically saying to anakin is
you're my only hope you blew it now we
don't have any hope
okay so this is actually extremely
interesting to me
because kind of adds a whole new layer
to the scene for me and also would have
changed
so much if they kept the sin because you
know it kind of shows you here that
anakin could have been redeemed
because it says here that anakin's eyes
turn from the blue to the sith red
only after obi-wan refused to help him
so if obi-wan
actually helped anakin i think we would
have got a completely different story
it's possible anakin could have actually
been redeemed right there
also this scene highlights obi-wan as
bit of a darker character than he is in
the scene
it shows him that he just completely
refuses anakin and
leaves him there to die with which is
quite brutal which you know he does do
in the um
original movie but in this deleted scene
he refuses anakin's plead for help
what's really interesting about this
scene is
anakin crying out for help because you
know revenge of the sith by the end of
the movie
darth vader is born and anakin is dead
but in this deleted scene
anakin is actually protruding out of
raider here and it shows you that
there's still light inside of anakin
and that there's a chance for him to be
redeemed but to be honest
even so that this deleted scene is more
emotional than what we already got i'm
kind of
glad that we didn't get this scene
because i like an original movie that it
shows you there's no hope for anakin
he's
turn evil and there's no turning back
whereas in this deleted scene
it kind of tells you that there's still
good inside of him because he's asking
for help a cry for help
so yeah these are my thoughts on this
deleted scene i would love to know what
you guys think of this deleted scene
so please tell me in the comment section
below and also do you want to see more
deleted scenes or you got any other
video suggestions
make sure to also tell me in the comment
section below with that out of the way
please like subscribe and i'll see you
guys in the next video
you